et on va maintenant parler de sport avec
Muriel Beauvilain donc vous êtes
championne de culturisme naturel et vous
avez disputé le championnat univers
assez où les 10 et 11 juin dernier vous
avez conclu concouru pour 4 catégories
et remporter la première place dans
trois catégories donc la catégorie
boutique pour les muscles du fessier
transformation pour la transformation la
plus spectaculaire glamour également
pour votre passage en scène avec une
robe de soirée et enfin vous êtes
arrivés en troisième position dans la
catégorie figure qui consiste à
démontrer toute la musculature du corps
alors c'est assez énorme j'imagine que
vous êtes plutôt fier de vos résultats
j'avoue que je suis assez fier parce que
je suis quand même un bébé de deux ans
de musculation donc parce qu'il y a
trois ans moi je faisais 107 kg donc
c'est vrai que c'est la catégorie
transformation c'est vraiment une grosse
revanche parce que personne n'y croyait
et donc je le fais et dans plusieurs
catégories donc
à arriver trois fois première et
troisième en figure devant deux athlètes
vraiment qui avait
beaucoup d'avance sur moi voilà sur
cette cette participante je suis très
fière et justement en parlant des
participants donc vous étiez en
concurrence contre combien de personnes
au total alors dans il y a beaucoup de
catégories donc moi dans mes 4
catégories en figure on était 7 en
renoué donc glamour on était 8
en transformation on était trois et on
vous dit on était trois aussi donc voilà
c'est il y avait de la bagarre quand
même
parler du coup de transformation que
vous avez perdu du poids que comment ça
s'est passé et en termes de
d'entraînement c'est à quelle fréquence
c'est combien d'heures par semaine
combien de jours
comment on fait pour en arriver
justement à ce niveau donc ben là je
vais parler plus de la prépa en soi
c'est 6 jours sur 7 quand même un jour
de repos parce que c'est dans le repos
aussi qu'on construit le muscle donc et
à raison de 2h30 à 3h quand on inclut du
cardio donc on a une demi-heure trois
quart d'heure voire une heure de cardio
donc c'est vrai que ça fait des séances
très intenses et du coup en plus c'est
quelque chose que vous cumulez avec un
autre emploi et vous êtes aussi
auxiliaire de vie et artiste peintre
donc ça fait de sacrées journées où tout
doit être paramétré régler réveil 6h
pour déjeuner préparer les gamelles pour
10h midi 15h 18h en fait on va manger
toutes les trois heures
justement de gérer ce rythme non bah au
début on se sent un peu submergé mais
après on prend l'habitude le corps prend
l'habitude et le la tête prend
l'habitude aussi et à la fin c'est plus
le mental qui a faim que le corps c'est
une question sur le culturisme naturel
qu'est-ce que c'est le culturisme
naturel c'est un autre type de
culturisme il y a des fédérations ou
l'emploi de produits sont utilisés pour
construire de la masse alors que dans le
culturisme naturel ben c'est bon
voilà donc ça ça demande tout autant de
travailler également quand on emploie
des produits mais voilà c'est là où se
fait la distinction et alors pour
revenir sur le concours comment ça
fonctionne ce qu'il y a une est-ce que
c'est mix ou est-ce qu'il y a une
catégorie spécifique pour les femmes
pour les hommes est-ce qu'il y a des
catégories en fonction des âges alors il
y a des il y a un peu tout ça il y a des
catégories pour les hommes les
catégories pour les femmes
pour transformation c'était tout mélangé
il y a des questions le poids pour les
hommes de
pas spécifiquement pour les femmes en
bikini en sport modèle ou en figure donc
c'est vraiment
séparé
pour les hommes il y a l'âge et le poids
en fait par exemple dans une catégorie
ça peut être
la hauteur moins l'âge moins le poids je
veux dire h - 6 pour 6 kg à -8 pour la
le ratio auteur taille
donc il y a plusieurs catégories
il y a plusieurs catégories et alors du
coup est-ce que c'est dur de s'imposer
dans ce milieu quand on est une femme
puisque culturisme c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a été longtemps
convoité un peu par les hommes
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui a
changé ça évolue alors les préjugés sont
toujours peuvent pas encore tenace je
sais que j'en ai encore de de lui dire
mais voilà au fur et à mesure vu que
c'est accessible et que il y a des
catégories pour toutes les personnes on
va dire bikini sport modèle donc toutes
les musculature tout les physiques
peuvent avec du travail avec de la
rigueur voilà peuvent se lancer dans le
culturisme Thomas et Jean-Emmanuel le
culturisme naturel c'est quelque chose
que vous connaissiez déjà vous en avez
entendu parler j'en ai entendu parler
vaguement mais c'est tout
alors moi je travaille sur plein de
choses mais je suis pas encore dans ce
domaine mais avec plaisir un jour et en
tout cas je suis très impressionnée
parce que faire tout ça c'est vraiment
extraordinaire bravo parce que ça
demande une organisation et puis
effectivement un mental assez assez fort
la durée il faut le début on est plein
d'entrain on y va mais au bout de cinq
six mois de prépa et quand on arrive au
moment de la sèche où on doit en
restriction calorique toujours
s'entraîner intensément c'est vrai que
il y a beaucoup de monde
alors la toute dernière question est-ce
que vous avez encore d'autres objectifs
des prochains événements qu'elle vous
souhaitez participer oui donc là en fait
pour 2024 en fait je vais me préparer
pour 2024 pour venir pour deux trois
compétitions donc à partir de septembre
je vais rentrer en pop pour une prise de
masse pour prendre encore des muscle et
revenir au mois d'avril
normalement pour pour d'autres
compétitions de coupe j'imagine et faire
en sorte de
d'augmenter un peu ma collection ce
serait le vide toi
merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en tout
cas on vous souhaite le meilleur et puis
nous on continuera à vous suivre dans
votre dans votre parcours avec plaisir